fallout 4 has no shortage of unique
weapons but did you ever get the feeling
that something was missing maybe a
certain energy blade from a popular
sci-fi series fret no more moderate
invalid fate has stepped up to fill that
saber sized void in your life with a new
mod for the pc version of fallout 4
available on nexus mods the lightsaber
renew mod allows you to gallivant
through enemy territory with your very
own lightsaber pick a color get the
slicing up Raiders and soaking the ever
familiar sounds from the film's a mod
and instructions on how to use it are
available over at nexus mods calm all at
four is hosted quite a bit of Star Wars
user created content label earlier this
month a dedicated fallout player created
a massive 8080 using the settlement
creator tools ask Iran's modding
community is any indication I'm sure
we'll see plenty more Star Wars mods for
the game in the near future now I just
need some Jedi robes a bb8 follower and
an x-wing and I can fend off the nagging
sense of anticipation while I wait for
episode 8 more star wars and everything
fallout related to stay tuned to
gamespot com